[موسيقى]
السوبر أخيرًا مرتين على التوالي إنه أ
شيء لم نشهده من قبل في فرنسا و
هنا ديدييه ديشامب أعتقد أنه
في القمة ونحن انتقائيون للغاية
كل معه في النهائي و
آمل أن نفوز بالمركز الثالث
نجمة
الاستماع انها مغامرة عظيمة و
أتمنى أن يفوز المنتخب الفرنسي
بعد ذلك ، إنها لحظة تماسك
وطني في فترة
نوعا ما صعبة للغاية ومعقدة
لكثير من الناس إذا كان ذلك ممكنًا
تجلب القليل من التماسك والأمل
كان ذلك أفضل بكثير
[موسيقى]
سعيد جدًا لأننا فزنا بذلك بالفعل
الصيف أنا حقا أنا جدا
لذلك سعداء وللمسيح لأجل
الأرجنتين لسنا خائفين لأنني
أعتقد أننا تغلبنا بالفعل منذ 4 سنوات
لذلك نحن كبار السن سيحاولون لنا
نقاتل وسنقلق بعضنا البعض
الفريق الزوجين
[موسيقى]